[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw
political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
is it already tuesday
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
it's tuesday
the day after memorial day how was your
holiday weekend
folks out there new listeners we have a
ton of them
thank you for joining us
tuesday tuesday tuesday
it is though
i wonder what
there there
there we go now it looks normal it
didn't look right i had one of my lights
off
sorry i i
i'm a little late this morning just a
few seconds late
it's been a a weird weekend with the
holiday but we're getting through it
we're getting through it there's new
there's new things happening
when the kids don't go to school anymore
so you're trying to
adjust in the morning so we're getting
through that but we'll we'll get a
routine down to where that happens so
thank you for joining us here on this
tuesday may 31st we're all the way
through may folks we're into june
and it seems like that may be why the
news is this morning the way it is is
because june is a big month
june is going to be a huge month in
american politics
because we're going to hear about the
january six select
hearings the public hearings you know
that we are going to stream them here on
the tony michael's podcast every single
one of them gavel to gavel
on the public select january 6 select
committee hearings
but also in the month of june we're
expected to receive
the late decision from the supreme court
so this morning we find out that the
supreme court is
requesting the law clerks hand over
their text messages this is all
distraction this is distraction from the
actual text messages that we're going to
see in these public hearings from an
actual wife of a supreme court justice
who was trying to overturn the united
states government who was trying to
commit a coup
that's right i said it
jeannie thomas and clarence thomas
these q and honors
have infiltrated the supreme court and
it needs to be investigated if we can
investigate a stupid [ __ ] leak of a
decision that they're going to make
to take away our rights we absolutely
absolutely can investigate and should
investigate
the coup attempt that happened by the
supreme court justice's wife she was
text messaging the chief of staff
all kinds of crazy ass q and stuff
we should not forget about this and we
should not believe or or [ __ ]
pay attention much
to the distraction of the leak
i i would imagine that we're gonna find
out that this leak investigation is not
going to lead down the road that they
want
and the media is buying all this [ __ ]
distraction
this watch this hand while we do this
other thing
watch this hand over here while we
commit a coup over here
that's what it is distraction
they're gonna distract us with the leak
of a decision that they're going to make
think about this for a second we're
supposed to believe
that the high crime that has been
committed in the supreme court is that
the decision that they're gonna make to
take away women's rights and liberties
of their body that they have
constitutionally in this country right
now
that that that leaked out
is the high crime that was committed in
the supreme court give me a [ __ ]
break
forget about
buying and paying for the justices the
right-wing coups that are on the supreme
court forget about that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] crime in the first place
how they bought and paid for it through
the federalist society
of making sure that minority ideology
rules in this country forget about that
for a second forget about how we can't
have 13 justices we have to have nine
which makes no sense we have 13
districts we should have 13 justices
that's the framing of the supreme court
it only makes common sense logic it's
not [ __ ] rocket science
but forget about that that part of it
forget about that part of it for a
second
we're supposed to believe that the high
crime that was committed in the supreme
court is someone leaked the decision
that they're gonna make this month
that that's it
we're not supposed to believe that the
wife of supreme court justice who was
texting
the chief of staff while the coup is
happening
while the coup is ongoing while donald
trump tried to take over our government
rip up the constitution and [ __ ] on it
throw it in the toilet and flush it i
guess i don't know it seems to be a
trend
but that's what we're supposed to
believe get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
and this morning when this report comes
out about these staffers or some [ __ ]
about text messages
we should be on a crusade folks this
morning yelling and screaming at the top
of our lungs continually
and we shouldn't stop again we're one
issue voters now we have to be one issue
voters because it is clear now more than
ever
what their mission is
their mission is to take away our
[ __ ] democracy take away our right as
a people to decide what
what and how we can keep kids safe in a
school
they want to take away our [ __ ] right
to do that
they want to take away our right as a
people to make sure that guns don't get
into the wrong hands
and that maybe some of these guns aren't
manufactured in the first place for pure
profit
they want to take away our rights to our
to our bodies women
don't even have the right to their
uterus in some states anymore
to medical decisions that are made
between them and their doctor about
their life
and we're supposed to believe this
morning that the big huge
controversy at the big huge crime
committed in this country
was a leak of a decision that they're
going to make
it's not like they're claiming oh my god
this person is
lying who cares who leaked it is
probably a right winger in the first
place
who gives a [ __ ]
that's probably what we're gonna find
out in the long run this investigation
and no investigation ever works out well
for these right wingers
we've seen that
i mean remember how important a certain
email lady's emails were several years
ago remember how important hunter
biden's laptop is to the biden
presidency remember that
give me a [ __ ] break these
investigations never [ __ ] pan out for
these morons and the reason why is
because they're always based in delusion
the entire thing their entire [ __ ]
political arguments are based in
contradictory delusion
jesus christ i found a meme the other
day of the guy pressing the button which
one to choose the one is oh these
[ __ ] teachers are the worst thing
ever in this country because they're
woke and they want to teach your kid crt
but they're the only thing that can
protect our kids if we just give them
guns
they spew [ __ ] out all their holes
it's a political contradiction
and it will continue that way this
morning they're mad
they're mad that these law clerks
have text messages
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here we know what
this we know
we know
what is going to happen with these
investigations it is not gonna show
it is not going to show that some
[ __ ]
lib [ __ ] [ __ ] lib libtard law clerk
lied about the decision because that's
what they're trying to make it into and
the mainstream media is buying this [ __ ]
hook line sinker hook line sinker don't
buy it
make the noise of the real [ __ ]
crimes that are being committed in the
supreme court
jeannie thomas the wife of clarence
thomas
that piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
was texting
the chief of staff who was standing next
to the person who was trying to
overthrow our government
and encouraging it not only encouraging
giving them ideas on how to overthrow
our constitution
and then
and then clarence thomas got to make
decisions on the evidence
without recusing himself you want to
talk about [ __ ] crimes
they can't stop crimin
they can't stop criming
we can't take our eye off the prize here
folks the prize is our democracy
it is at stake every [ __ ] waking
moment we have to fight for it
everywhere because these fascists are
not going to stop
they're not going to stop spreading
their lies they're not going to stop
spreading their propaganda
they're not going to try they're not
going to stop trying to bang up our
democracy
so we must we must be loud we must yell
and scream
we must get in their faces we must make
these fascists feel uncomfortable it is
enough of [ __ ] making these fascists
feel like they're they have a place
in our political body no you do not you
can be fascist in this country you can
have your fascist ways you can wave your
nazi flags but that does not mean we
have to allow you to be part of our
[ __ ] apparatus of the government
we get to decide we the people get to
decide who represent us in this
constitutional democratic republic
in this democracy we get to decide not
you [ __ ]
so now is the time now right now get
engaged
whether you're in the state that has a
senate race or a governor race state
legislator all the way down to the
[ __ ] dog catcher
give money give time
yell and scream go to protest march
if you can't do those things make phone
calls text message talk to your family
members talk to your community tell them
about the issues that matter and the
issue that matters the most is our
democracy and how they want to [ __ ]
squash it
and they don't care by what means they
really don't give a [ __ ] they don't care
they just want to have power and control
over us
that's what they want
they will do anything to get it
absolutely anything even go to an nra
convention
a bloodbath celebration after 19
children are slaughtered
and say things like banning back doors
and ready government regulation for back
doors
is the answer to protecting children
this is really [ __ ] dumb
this is really [ __ ] stupid and yes
i'm not gonna shut up about that either
i'm not gonna shut up about about them
slaughtering our children i'm not going
to shut up about them banning math
banning education for our children i'm
not going to shut up about them wanting
to marry and take away our consent for
our children i'm not going to shut up
about that either i'm not going to shut
up about them taking
the right to women's bodily autonomy
away i'm not gonna shut up about it i'm
not gonna shut up about how they're
gonna tell us who we can love and who we
can [ __ ] i'm not gonna shut up about it
i'm not gonna shut up about the fact
that these fascists tried to overthrow
our constitutional government ours our
vote i'm not gonna shut up about it i'm
not
you could take it from a cold dead hands
as they would say about guns
and you shouldn't either
one issue voters folks one [ __ ] the gop
[ __ ] them
they have proven themselves time and
time and time again every day every
single hour jesus christ it feels like
every 30 seconds they prove why we
should not have them in power anywhere
in our democracy anywhere absolutely
anywhere school board
state legislature governor
you name the united states senate
we've seen a lot of video over the
weekend of these [ __ ] boneheads
marjorie taylor green herschel walker
lauren bobert i mean it just is an
endless
barrage of [ __ ] stupid
and these are the people that want power
and they're willing to do anything
anything absolutely anything to get it
and it's up to us it's up to us
not just to vote it's not just about
voting everyone yeah tony
tony we already vote well there's
that's right we do vote we should vote
there was eight million more people that
said no to fascism in 2020 because i
don't believe 81 million people voted
for biden
that is the thing that i agree with the
queue and honors with i don't believe 81
million people voted for biden i think a
hell of a lot of that 81 million voted
against trump
it's time we start voting against these
[ __ ]
it's time yes yes you're not going to
get everything you want in every shape
and form that you want it you are not
going to receive every piece of gun
legislation that you ever dreamed of
you're not going to get your entire
[ __ ] student debt taken away you're
not going to receive absolute no cost
health care at you to you immediately
it's not going to happen that way
but do you think the alternative
do you think the alternative to sit and
do nothing to do nothing for your
democracy to do nothing for your
community to do nothing for your family
you think the alternative to let them
have power
is going to get you even closer to those
things that you that you think your
democracy that we the people should form
a better society
you think that's going to get you closer
the people who wanted to overthrow the
constitution
the thing that we are grasping on to and
holding on to for dear life here you
think they're going to give you your
constitutional rights
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
banning math of florida because crt
shows up in the book they want to marry
children in tennessee
they want anyone anyone absolutely
anyone to have a gun in texas
and they're excited about people having
guns in texas pew pew pew pew pew we
need to buy more guns we need to outgun
california
in oklahoma they're banning pregnancy at
boners
at boners boners are human beings now in
oklahoma
before conception they're saying life
begins before conception speaking of
that we have kirk cameron on the
trending list that dumb [ __ ]
right kirk cameron you are a dumb
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] bigot
we cannot relent we cannot back down we
cannot we can not stop they won't and
they're not going to you have to get
politically engaged even if you don't
know a lot about politics it's fine even
if you don't know a lot about government
it's fine you we can we can do it
together we could do it together yes
it's very hard to pass gun legislation
yes it is very difficult to cancel
student debt in this country god damn
it's hard to even protect our [ __ ]
vote
but we have to do everything we can
everything that we can to do that
we cannot stop they will not stop
they won't stop trying to take our
democracy away from us why do you think
these people are out there they're in
your comments i know they're we're not a
democracy we're a republic that's what
they say right we're not a democracy we
are never intended to be a democracy
they say stupid [ __ ] really stupid [ __ ]
who gives a flying ass [ __ ]
what the founding father said
a bunch of [ __ ] a bunch of [ __ ]
white dudes property owning white dudes
protecting their rights
well they [ __ ] up they made a
constitution that was a living document
and we made that document protect our
rights
people of color women children
migrants
they have [ __ ] rights too
and we should not have to [ __ ] fight
over one amendment in this country there
are plenty of them plenty of amendments
the pile on top of these [ __ ]
these [ __ ] fascists
and yeah
some are upset oh they're not in prison
yet blah blah blah peter navarro is in
the [ __ ] news this morning the doj
he he has some news i i am read the
entire [ __ ] report but we're gonna go
through it today
it is obvious doj is operating
to prosecute
the criminals that tried to overthrow
our government it is more than obvious
and this nonsense out there of
questioning the doj is
authoritarian-like it's trump-like
stop doing it stop it
you're only making the case for them
only making the case for them
of authoritarianism is good stop acting
like you want
merrick garland to be a bill barr stop
it
stop it
that's not the answer that's not the
answer
authoritarianism is not the answer here
in a democracy
democracy is difficult it's hard it's
the long road really like
if you were to choose how fast you're
going to get to what you want
personally
it's the long road it really is the long
road because in democracy you're not
always going to get everything you
absolutely want whether it's to cancel
your entire student debt or part of it
rather it's to get your child's
education to start at three instead of
five maybe it starts at four instead of
five i mean some people want it to start
at birth
i mean life begins at birth shouldn't
education
some people want it to go beyond
21 for education
some people want it to stop there some
people want it to stop at 16 so they can
marry your children
but we're not all gonna get exactly what
we want you're not it's a democracy
but that doesn't mean that democracy is
not the road to equality and equity
it it is the road to equality and equity
and it is a long hard fight
why do you think they love
authoritarianism you think these
fascists these trumped up fascists out
there these moglodites
you think they like authoritarianism
for any other reason than it it's it's
for the stupid it's for the dumb minded
it's the easy way it's the easy way to
get what you want to choose the person
who absolutely will do everything say
they will do everything you want
just because he says it
not because he'll do it he was supposed
to lock her up and build a wall remember
he didn't do [ __ ] either of those
goddamn things
he didn't lock hillary up jesus christ
even after the fact they couldn't even
get a special prosecutor to prosecute a
one person in that [ __ ] case not one
[ __ ]
acquitted
the wall that they built [ __ ] blew
over with the stiff goddamn wind and
they're still complaining about people
coming across the border well i thought
you voted for him to fix the
[ __ ] and he didn't he won't
but they don't care it's not about
actual
[ __ ]
work
it's not about actual policy being put
in place it's only about their whiteness
feeling good
that's right i said it it's about their
whiteness and their white privilege
feeling nice and cozy that way they can
continue to be snowflakes
because that's the rub folks even on
this gun issue they remember with the
covet they just pray and god's gonna
protect them well what the [ __ ] do you
need a gun for then if god's gonna
protect you
what the [ __ ] do you need a gun for if
god's gonna protect you you didn't need
a mask what do you need a gun for you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
now is the time to fight for this
democracy it's worth it
it's more than worth it
and if you don't believe me that it's
worth it just go out on the right-wing
sites and see how much they hate
democracy
just see how much they're scared of it
how afraid they are of it they're
terrified of democracy
terrified of it
the nazis hate it
the moglodites hate it
the republicans hate it
why do you think they hate democracy so
much
why
why you think they hate it so much i can
tell you why
it will end
their party it will end fascism
now i can't stop an idea but it damn
sure can keep it out of our [ __ ]
government
if we the people participate in the
democracy participate not just vote
but actually participate in our
democracy that is the key
that is the key we have a lot of
subjects today we have a special guest
joining us today i believe
uh you guys seen the video sp speaking
fascist speaking of
dumb bucks ted cruz
uh was approached in a restaurant
by a person who's very passionate
about making sure gun violence isn't
rampant all over his state
his name is benjamin hernandez you've
seen him in the viral video where he
made sure to make ted cruz feel
uncomfortable
make him feel uncomfortable
so what he should feel is uncomfortable
especially after he gets done
at a gunless gathering where they cheer
the bloodbath that was yuvaldi texas
talking about banning backdoors
and talking about how the elites are the
problem and then his elite dumbass gets
in a limo and drives across town to one
of the fanciest [ __ ] sushi
restaurants in one of the wealthiest
parts of town
where he won't be accosted
and benjamin
let him have it we've seen it in the
video and we have benjamin going to be
joining us today
here in just a bit
we're going to go through the tweety
tweets and trinity turns but i want to
welcome all the new listeners holy moly
gabe we've got a ton of new listeners
out here can you believe how many new
listeners we have this i can't but i
will i just want to say i'm super
grateful and i know jenny is too
abs absolutely i i love all the new
listeners i even there we have a few
trolls in the chat this morning it seems
like on facebook
yeah we like the trolls here yeah man as
long as you're not saying any kind of
crazy racist you know big stuff or
you're not you're not you're not going
after
uh people in the chat as long as you're
having a civil conversation in the chat
you are welcome here at the tony
michael's budget yes you are welcome
here to use your freedom of speech
because we believe in it because if i
didn't believe it hell they shut me up
really damn quick right really really
yeah
but today we have a special guest um and
you contacted ben i believe um for the
interview so yeah let's tell us before
we get to the trendy trends what time
has been going to be joining us by the
way i think uh he should be arriving at
uh on the the top of the second hour
okay okay so we got about 30 minutes to
see some tweets and stuff right so tell
us tell us about your conversation with
ben but more more than that because i
want everyone to understand who who ben
is because he's just not i mean he is a
citizen and he is a conservative person
in texas but he he has a passion for
making sure schools are safe and the
community is safe that we have sensible
common sense gun safety right and he's
advocated it for a long time so tell
them a little bit about uh benjamin
hernandez and what his history is before
so yeah so benjamin hernandez um is an
activist you know uh
gun rights gun control is definitely a
pillar that he believes in something
that we should push for he's a father so
i think
this uh and he'll probably speak more to
it during the interview but this is
definitely something that kind of
um speaks true to him and something that
is very important and it is definitely
something that uh if you if you somehow
missed a video this weekend there were a
couple that were out there but there was
a person that confronted ted cruz while
he was at a restaurant calling him out
and saying that the 19 children the
blood was on his hands it was all you
know it was on him he's not doing
anything about it
um and that he should do more
and if you saw the video either one uh
the guy who is kind of
starting to speak and then getting
pulled out and escorted from the
restaurant that was benjamin hernandez
so
that is the activist he will be on the
show in a little bit
um and so i reached after i saw the
video i reached out i was like hey we'd
love to have you on the show give you a
platform to just say what you want to
say since clearly ted cruz and his
security didn't let you say everything
you wanted to say so i figured
um you know he can come on the show talk
more about the experience talk more
about what he's passionate about what he
want you know the the things that he
actually wants to say and and for all
the new viewers you know give him
um
just just an area to
to say what he needs to say out to all
these people um you know i've got um
here i've got the uh the viral video and
we'll probably play the the fuller video
that they were actually shooting um when
he was talking to uh senator
ted scumbag i mean cruz right um but
here is the vir this is the this is the
portion of the video because this is a
bystander
right he's in the restaurant this is the
one that went viral first right um this
is where um the scuffle you know it
started to get loud so someone pulled
out their phone let's take a listen to
this
hunger
[Applause]
so that that's the uh the original video
that went right viral it's about 20
seconds and it's the
close to the end of the uh
um right where ben hernandez was
actually telling ted cruz um where to
stick it i guess you could say yeah
and they were escorting him his security
and other people were escorting him out
of the restaurant um i i really think
that
we should make these people feel
uncomfortable not just in sushi
restaurants but everywhere about their
political views right i mean they should
have to answer for their political views
and again this goes back to supreme
court which is in the news again today
the supreme court's in the news again
today because they're looking for the
leaker gabe oh that's the big story blue
the leaker holy boy
oh boy
that's the problem they're like really
taking away people's rights right right
yeah taking away people's rights here's
the thing what we'll probably find out
is the leaker with someone that's
actually a right-wing clerk or someone
else on the right and then they're gonna
be like oh
uh let's um
let's move on to uh right trying to
marry kids huh right right yeah let's do
that let's do that let's ban back doors
let's have a lot of back door
conversations
so yeah you know it is complete
projection you know immediately they
come after and say it was the left wing
you know we've talked about it before
wouldn't be surprised if it honestly was
someone on the right wing that released
in an attempt to
uh
kind of i don't know if it was
bring down any hope that people had in
terms of
roe v wade or you know it was an early
kind of
kind of push to
to show everyone that you know
i think i think it's actually a
distraction from
uh and that's the actual january 6th
select committee because they knew they
knew all these public hearings were
going to be in june um they thought
maybe that this that that decision would
fly under the radar and right-wingers
wouldn't be excited about it which i
think they really underestimate things
in this country like they really
underestimated that the majority of
people in this country look at uvalde
and go
oh you're a good guy with the gun
argument that's [ __ ] right oh that's
oh oh that was all [ __ ] that's all
actual [ __ ] and and and
that talk about anything anything
anything but the gun
right i can't have a conversation with
anyone but the gun even even blame it on
backdoors and blame it on a teacher
that this happened it really it really
tells you they're gonna they're gonna go
they're gonna you know they blame it on
the teacher they're gonna blame it on
the door prop they're gonna be like
we need to ban door props so we need to
make sure that when you get in the
building we are chain linking this door
you cannot go in you cannot go out i
mean like trump said in his uh
his nra speech he was talking about one
point of entry high wall security
technology that would deter you from
bringing a weapon in like right but the
answer is a prison
right but the answer is gabe once you
make it a prison you need to pepper guns
throughout the school in that prison for
each teacher to have because that means
everyone's on a shift they're all
they're all right in the hallways let's
make sure
right let's make sure we spend a lot of
time and energy to make prisons or
jesus christ schools prisons would have
would have slipped there to make schools
prisons to make sure guns don't get
inside so then what we have to do is
make sure there's
guns inside like
in in most prisons
there are certain um spots in those
prisons that there are no firearms yeah
past a certain spot there's a reason why
there's no firearms past a certain spot
like there's a reason it's because a gun
can be dangerous
it can be deadly
it can be deadly too it's almost people
you know they they look at and they say
hey guys it's not a great idea to uh
put a large population at risk by
introducing a weapon that can cause a
great amount of damage even if it's a
single round you know handgun
and they look at that and they say yeah
it's probably not a smart idea right
well
so much so that they banned they banned
firearms inside the nra gunless
gathering i mean they had a sign out
front this is this is a little satirical
sign out front that good liars put up we
showed this yesterday it says no
firearms allowed inside the nra nra
event because guns are dangerous and we
are massive hypocrites like literally
they understand the stakes here so much
so that they understand the stakes that
they will not allow a loaded weapon to
be brought inside of a gun convention
where they are like yeah we should be
able to carry anywhere and anywhere and
it's our god-given right i mean besides
here because it's [ __ ] dangerous yeah
it's dangerous
we know it's dangerous and so we don't
want to put ourselves at risk and like
obviously the sign you know they're like
the social they're the the secret
service has alerted us and told us that
we cannot allow these you know objects
like the list of things that are on
there you've got everything from a toy
gun to an umbrella to a selfie stick
well those selfie sticks gave i i just
said these shows that these things are
extremely dangerous i mean they could
take
really good
um pictures that have a lot of depth to
them yeah when you're taking a picture
yourself that can be very dangerous when
someone like ted cruz or donald trump is
taking
a picture of themselves with the selfie
stick this could be especially people
like ted cruz who is part of the elite
class
does live in a gated community who does
have millions of dollars yet decides to
speak down to people as if he
was just a normal person he is just a
normal average
elite dude who went to princeton and
yale you know all the stuff that normal
averages he went to harvard which is oh
yeah
excuse me excuse me excuse me
i didn't i didn't mean to insult i
didn't mean well you know tony he went
to harvard so he's wicked smart you know
which again you know if anything this
proves you that you uh don't have to be
smart to go to an ivy league school guys
so
[ __ ] [ __ ] ted cruz ted cruz what a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] and i can't i
can't wait to actually get um benjamin's
take on like
you know did he get to say the things
that he want did he did he expect the
response right those are the kind of
things that i wanna then i wanna ask ben
but let's do this first let's go through
some tweety tweets and trendy trends
because i think um there's a lot of
stuff going on out there that we need to
get to yeah as well as get prepared for
the interview with benjamin hernandez
but let's start the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast you have reached the
part of the show where we surf the
tweety tweets in the training trends
game
did you hear about the mona lisa being
attacked i did we should ban cake i'm
just saying i will dude i mean i mean we
might as well look right when we're in
that'll really piss the right wingers
off in the chat right yeah let's uh
pancake
but also if i remember correctly reading
this i mean she's you know the painting
is protected obviously right right it's
buying like glass right like some sort
of it's got yeah yeah
uh
that is unfortunate
that that happened right
but
yeah we should ban cake man cake reform
you know what they should do and smear
it too tony you know what they should do
they should make sure that wherever the
mona lisa is that the back doors there's
no back doors i mean that's why i got in
there i mean like he probably came in
through the back door right you know
maybe you know there's a whole play he
hid inside the cake then he popped out
of the cake then he grabbed the cake and
then he smeared it you know everyone's
like oh look a big cake mona lisa's
birthday or something you know and then
boom
smeared it virginia on facebook does not
like the cake band idea i don't either
look i i would i would be i would be
skin and bones here on the show if we
banned cake i'm a [ __ ] cake eater
that's just how it works so i i don't
believe we should pancake it it was just
a joke just kidding around just a joke
don't take it seriously right right but
here's here's you're talking about a
joke have you seen this kirk cameron
this is this is the only thing i just
want to point out that kirk cameron who
is completely irrelevant the only time
he makes himself relevant is by making
some video
that ron or someone else covers
and shares because
his takes are terrible it's all about
pro-christianity he wants to control
women blah blah blah same gqp type
[ __ ]
you know he's a watcher
this guy really is the jon voigt of greg
locks i mean he like he really is i
don't know i almost want to put him in
for uh a little bit of a ricky schroeder
oh really so he's like the ricky
schroeder well cameron is the ricky
showder of greg lock should i tweet that
out i don't know yeah yeah well i also
think he's like not quite like he's
getting a beard growing gray hair i
think he's on the path to becoming
a ricky schroeder right he needs to grow
it out and really slick it back like don
jr they're all copying me they're [ __ ]
i'm telling you they're copying me this
is ridiculous this is why i can't and i
won't grow a beard well oh because you
don't want to look like yeah because i
don't want to look like that actually
you know what you know what it is they
think growing a beard is manly that's
why
that's why they're they're doing it
right it's not because they like to wear
facial hair they're like well i must i
must look like a man have you ever seen
the video of um this [ __ ] bonehead
talking about um circumventing logic
with religion he's like look
people have logic and you have to you
have to go around you have to circumvent
their logic there's this thing instead
of like directly hitting it i want you
to go around to the back door right and
find a way in there and try definitely
definitely gaslight the holy [ __ ] out of
them
no pun intended on the holy [ __ ] thing
um but here this guy this [ __ ] guy
i just
man
he really he he really he really could
shut the [ __ ] up not soon enough um yeah
but i mean it is it is a a thing in this
country where you can say the dumbest
[ __ ] possible we've seen that um this
weekend with marjorie taylor green
and her peach tree dish but by the way
you [ __ ] out there with this peach tree
and i i contributed to it a little bit i
cannot i can't say it right you can't
not say i have i can't i i can't say
peach
peach
it's peach peach right but yes but in
your mind now you're doing i cannot
[ __ ] do it don't say peach street
don't say petrie [ __ ] i said peachtree
right you [ __ ] she ruined it and you
run it because you everyone spread it
around i i will never i will never be
able to say it correctly ever again i
will always sound like a dumb
[ __ ] when i say pea tree dish
cause i'm gonna say
right p like you piss right yeah and now
now people are gonna be like wait are
you saying pea tree right right because
you're gonna have to think about it and
go pee tree dish they're like boy that
cadence yeah but i'm trying not to say
peach tree dish which is now what i want
to say because i can't [ __ ] stop
seeing it hearing it in my brain
ah that's how propaganda works folks you
just have to repeat it over and over and
over again it's a good thing that it was
a peach tree dish you know who i think
would love a good pea tree dish who's
that
donald trump mm-hmm yeah oh the p-tape
thing yeah yeah
maybe that's maybe that maybe we should
get pea tree
dish trending just to get it back in
line here just right yeah yeah just to
get people right it's [ __ ] ridiculous
let's listen to this bonehead say
whatever the hell pukes out of his [ __ ]
hole here let's listen for their country
uh they don't want to abandon their
children to a system that uh by and
large is doing more grooming
for leftist politics
and see that's what he's really mad
about right
like it's hard to hear this [ __ ]
it sounds like he's doing an interview
and here's the problem
this guy's got an airpod in right yeah
he's got an airplane so cool he's got an
airpod in well here's the thing is apple
is kind of you know tim apple you know
tim apple yeah he got introduced to the
concert
with tim apple
is a leftist right he's a leftist and
here kirk cameron is indoctrinated into
tim apple's leftist company
um but he's so much so that he's buying
airpods and he thinks it's a good idea
to wear an airpod for an outside
interview which is not a
not a good idea because you can't hear a
[ __ ] thing kurt
you can't hear a [ __ ] thing you get a
[ __ ] microphone for crying he got
those noise canceling ones so it's like
apple big tech is trying to cancel him
oh that's what it is they're trying to
make his voice that's probably what it
is you're probably right
but here he's talking about left wing
left wing
he wants right wing is what he's saying
here again it's all projection with
these [ __ ] what he's saying is we want
right wing propaganda we want right wing
thinking we want to press our right wing
ideas on you
and what he doesn't understand is
education inherently isn't left-wing or
right-wing if you're seeing politics in
facts and history it's because you don't
want to hear those things because it
doesn't suit your fancy it doesn't suit
your narrative it doesn't fit what your
ideology is when you hear hey our
founding fathers they were [ __ ] slave
owners
they owned slaves they wrote the
constitution for white
property owning men to be free but not
slaves and not women but they also
created that document to be changed and
we've changed it throughout the years
that now we have this ability that's the
thing that that is the thing that it
happened it's a living right document
right like an organism
an orgasm don't say orgasm around kirk
cameron sorry sorry sorry well listen
listen to this listen to this last part
because i gotta i really gotta say
um
well let's listen and i'll i'll talk
about sexual chaos sexual chaos and
racial confusion then they are doing any
real educating about truth beauty and
goodness let's listen again politics
and sexual chaos
let's listen to it again large is doing
more grooming
for leftist politics
and sexual chaos
and racial confusion so grooming if you
can't hear out there because his [ __ ]
apple aeropods suck ass and he's
standing outside maybe he didn't buy
maybe it is an apple maybe he bought
like the non-like he bought a generic
time you know like one that you buy
online
like a third person like [ __ ] apple but
i want what apple looks like
i want to copy them but he said
grooming for leftist politics
sexual chaos gabe mm-hmm
and racial confusion now where the [ __ ]
is wrong i am no i that's exactly what i
tweeted this morning i'm like look i'm
all for sexual chaos that sounds like a
really cool thing right yeah i i am i am
for a hell of a lot of sexual chaos that
sounds like fun yeah but the racial
confusion what in the [ __ ] does that
like he's he's confused what race he is
i don't know i don't understand what he
might be saying is he might be saying
that those
like others out there
are trying to find where they align
racially like oh i'm maybe like because
like for instance i'm half white i'm
half hispanic so like maybe i don't know
if he's referring to that confusion
well maybe or he's like he's like hey
man i don't see color so like i'm
racially confused
is that what he's saying
well yeah it's always projection with
these [ __ ] right so you gotta
look at the eyes of projection number
one he says grooming a leftist politics
which means they want to groom children
to believe in their politics that's what
he's saying and then he says sexual
chaos which means i would imagine that
kirk cameron he did a vid he did a movie
one time about is he porno well obsessed
with pornography oh right right he did a
christian movie where he was obsessed
with porno so i would imagine that this
guy is josh howling at all over right
right do you think he did for that movie
do you think he did a lot of research
for that or i think he's like
he's probably still doing research and
the sexual chaos thing maybe it
borderlines on you know madison
catherine type activity i don't know
what kirk cameron's up to but i'm not
against uh some what was that what was
the other one charlie kirk said what
sexual deviance
what did he say
no no no no that was um um what was that
charlie kirk did say something you got
to look that up and it's a different
kirk people it's a different curve this
is kirk cameron
sexual anarchy yeah anarchy well that's
a little different that's a little
different than
chaos
you know
i mean i'm not i'm for both really
honestly maybe we should have a little
section i mean actually look look maybe
i mean whatever that baby is but yeah i
would love to live in a world where
there was sexual anarchy and chaos like
oh my god how liberating would that be
right so many people would be like oh my
god the stretch the stress and tension
of my life and and and my emotional
state was just relieved because i was
able to [ __ ]
let it out you know and sexual anarchy
all over the place right yeah here's the
thing the last one the racial confusion
maybe it's projection maybe this guy did
like a 23 and me you know that that that
you know i think that's where they
really get pissed off about this race
stuff right he's like racial confusion
like he took a 23andme and he found out
uh oh
right oh [ __ ]
this narrative is really go and that's
where his racial confusion is going he's
trying to project that hey
if you're confused about your race don't
don't fret confusion is just a left-wing
deep state idea and 23 and me is just
trying to convince you that you're not
fully right and that's your racial
confusion i don't know yeah
it's just you know 23 and me big tech
trying to tell you who you are right you
know you're like no man my grandpaper
said i was 100 wide you know i don't
know why yeah
figure this out i can't figure it out it
is it is i don't know man kirk cameron
here
the only good thing that came out of
growing pains
was leonardo dicaprio okay that's that's
and that that is heavily debatable like
like you could even you could even have
good strong arguments on either side of
that
on either side of that issue man i mean
i i i like me some leo movies but
he is kind of a weird dude right like
well yeah at least he doesn't stand in
the middle of a field
you know talking about how we should get
rid of um yeah like sexually anarchy
like did you own that farm because there
what looked to be like a tractor on the
back there there is a tractor back there
i don't know
but yes uh agreed leo is debatable you
know kirk cameron definitely not
debating yeah but in terms of talent
though oh absolutely talent absolutely
on on acting
kirk cameron is a one hit wonder
wannabe christian fascist superstar
probably cries when he masturbates
and you know well that's that's his own
sexual chaos gabe and you stay out of it
okay hey look i'm not trying to i'm not
trying to open that door i'm not trying
to go in that back door i'm not trying
to do anything we're banning back yours
gabe maybe that's i know maybe that's
why they're banning back doors i don't
know it seems like projection to me
number eight on the trend list is
trudeau a canadian prime minister oh it
looks like someone's trying to get done
announces uh new gun control legislation
it seems like to me and i've read a bit
of this um
the arguments back and forth it it feels
like to me what justin trudeau is really
saying with this gun legislation and
what they're trying to do is say we have
manufactured enough handguns we have
enough of them we don't need any more of
them at this point like we already have
too many like at some point there's just
it's just an excess right there's just
excess of hand do you need more than one
right and it seems like that's the main
thrust of this legislation in canada um
is to
just to pause um if that would be a
correct word because it's not really
banning they're just pausing new new
handguns being yeah they're just saying
the sale and production of guns to be
paused right because it's like we got
enough of them until we don't have
enough of them you know we're just gonna
i mean it's just like here in the us
right like i know everyone's like oh
they're gonna take away our guns and
it's like no dude just [ __ ] register
the gun properly train to use the gun uh
re-register the gun every year that you
know tell us where you [ __ ] own the
gun we're not gonna come get it
but if you're gonna store it somewhere
like it should be good to know like
don't keep it on your bed you know but
whatever people are going to do what
they are going to do and people are
going to be dumb
and it's just like
people are dumb people are really dumb
speaking of the word gun top gun number
i saw this yesterday this is pretty cool
um i i i'm not a big huge top gun fan i
know it's kind of a pop culture thing
right watch the movie it's been a long
time i haven't seen the new movie i mean
who doesn't love a good beach volleyball
scene all right right well you know it
happens um i don't know there's some
kirks out there that might disagree with
that kind of sexual chaos and sexual
anarchy but top gun um maverick the the
sequel here breaks a 15-year memorial
day box office record with 156 million
gabe i think the movie industry um was
really doomed and no one thought that it
would ever come back after covet but
yeah i think time and time again every
single week every single month we're
proving uh that this industry is coming
back with full force people want to go
out people want to go to the theater
yeah um
and i think that's actual good news i
know that doesn't seem like politics or
or social news but i think that's
actually no i think it's a really good
sign for the economy it's really good
it's a really good sign for our culture
too to to reacclimate ourselves back to
a society that that doesn't have this
fear that we we can go and be safe and
we're not going to contract a deadly
pathogen right i think that's important
yeah it's been you know i've gone to see
a few movies since like everything kind
of opened to back up and it has been
nice because like i love movies and you
know i can watch as many as i want
obviously for my home and watch as many
shows but there's a whole different
experience that happens like in my
popcorn i get my you know sprites
soda
when you pay 30 for popcorn and water
that
that's part of the experience right but
i think it is i think it is a good sign
um that our our country is getting back
to the things that are what we
considered pre-covered normal i think
that's i think that's super super
important um
you know
to not just not just our politics but
also our society right i think that's uh
important so it is it that's definitely
reassuring um it's good to see
mj with the super chat here she says gun
reform now abolish the nra
um we're gonna talk more about this
coming up here in just a few minutes
with benjamin hernandez and what he told
ted cruz and what his intention was but
before that i want to get to some more
tweety tweets here um i find it kind of
funny that wine is trending at 15
and then paul pelosi is trending at
number 17. it seems if these two things
are kind of like the other here as
everyone knows paul pelosi my husband
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
was arrested for dui charges i think um
it seems like you're right
or something yeah yeah he got a dui
and uh nancy was like or at least her
her her rep was like we will not comment
on this as she was on the east coast
right she wasn't in the car in the end
right right right like it was not and
she wasn't involved in it but her
husband was so the argument is is that
nancy pelosi is a criminal and um
impeach her from the speaker of the
house i don't know what their argument
is i don't know i guess well i would
probably
but i think some people are probably
gonna make the argument that it's like
oh is he gonna get off
like get out of this situation wait is
this another sexual anarchy no no no no
okay okay okay no no okay
gutter from kirk cameron her camera
keeps my mind
i mean hey that's how this is all right
they infect you with that i know those
ideas you know you're like like a jd
vance trying to control porn right well
you know it happens it happens um
but no over the weekend the discussion
was that people were having was like oh
are people um are we gonna see
paul pelosi get out of this without any
sort of repercussion
which is similar i mean he shouldn't
he should he should get the same
punishment that everyone else gets in
the state of california for this deal
you broke the law you should be punished
he shouldn't be over punished he
shouldn't be under punishment he should
just receive the same punishment that
everyone else now some people were
saying that he should receive the same
type of treatment that matt gates
received from his father's connection
after he got duis
so you know i'm not saying that he
should get that they do bring up an
issue point which is like if you are
politically connected you do have the
luxury
and security
to
get away from something that might be
permanent well and that's a good point
and i guess that's the reason why i
bring this story up because a lot of
people like oh no one will ever bring up
this story if you're for left-wing
politics number one i'm not always a fan
of nancy pelosi i'm not i'm not always a
fan of chuck schumer i'm not i don't i
don't believe that the way that they do
politics is the correct way and i don't
even know paul pelosi i don't even know
him i do know things about him now and
that he likes to drink wine in napa and
the guy doesn't probably use his cranium
when he decides whether he's going to
drive or not that was another point that
people pointed out like oh my god well
you think paul pelosi with all that
money would be able to afford a
chauffeur why why do you think
why do you think people are running
around only being chauffeur places um
this is a good argument though i guess
he could afford an uber ride he could
afford a cab probably but i don't know
the situation i don't know if he had a
half a glass too much he was right at
the limit but here's the thing
that i think is worth pointing out if
paul pelosi was so powerful and these
politicians were so powerful to get out
of this don't you think that paul pelosi
wouldn't have even been arrested and
given a citation
um for the dui in the first place so i
think that's actually a sign that hey it
doesn't matter if it's paul pelosi or
anyone else if he gets pulled over with
the dui he's going to get the ticket
he's going to get arrested whatever the
case is whatever the
crime for the punishment that is suited
for that county that city that state he
received it um because that's how we
know about it he wasn't just let go
because he is paul pelosi so you know
this idea that the system doesn't work
and the system is only to work against
us
of course we need to perfect it of
course we need to get better and better
and better
which maybe paul pelosi being arrested
is a sign of that that's all i'm saying
yeah no i
and you know it's one of those things of
like
uh are we hearing about this
and is that the reason something will be
done you know i mean it should be done
regardless but you know it's one of
those things where
you know you have to look at kind of the
events and say like oh is
will he be punished only because it
became a public thing
you know which is unfortunate um because
it should be you should be punished
based on the crime that was committed
um if you broke the law you broke the
law and that's how everyone should be
and you know as
as opposed to like oh it's hush hush and
somebody gets a call from the station to
say like hey so-and-so's in here you
want to get them out right now okay
we're going to let them out through the
back door tony
the back door baby we need to ban them
back doors there you go kevin says here
don't don't drink
i i think he means don't drink and drive
he reposted it somewhere yeah
don't drink it it should be that easy
right right right well and again and
again there are there are laws there is
regulation which is funny when we talk
about alcohol and driving there's a lot
of regulation around driving and alcohol
but um
you you are there is a legal limit um
and some people think you shouldn't have
any alcohol and drive which sounds like
it was kevin but i don't i don't think
people should drink and drive either
that's not what i'm advocating what i'm
saying is that paul pelosi broke the law
um and the law should hold him
accountable and seems like at this point
it is going to hold them accountable
right and that's why nancy pelosi won't
speak on the issue which she probably
can't right she wasn't there she doesn't
know
why
she was on the entire opposite side of
the country why would she speak to the
issue other than
hey what's gonna happen is what's gonna
happen he obviously
and
what appears to be from the evidence
that he had too much to drink and he was
illegally driving so
um
just a point now back to the peach tree
dish it's still trending see what you
[ __ ] are doing it is you're
even you're you're contributing number
24.
number 24. this is why i can't we'll
never be able to say it correctly again
i'm bad enough about english the way it
is
you're ever
cursed you're forever cursed i know
people i'm sorry that's how it is you
are you know like i said i said this was
a dish
that was
oh man what did my tweet say i said uh i
say this memorial day
make sure to avoid
margie taylor green's
peach tree dish it's like like a like a
peach casserole kind of right right and
i said it's a rare
uh dessert
that was passed down from her ancestors
oh baby
is it a great dessert to watch yourself
but you know
not i don't have the opportunity a lot
to say
the actual word petri dish i know i
don't get that opportunity like you're
not intelligent
i'm not even trying to interject that
word most of the time right like you
could try to find a conversation with
someone to get to that
here you want it you want to know how to
use it you would say something like
um uh republican lawmakers are
uh in a petri dish of
i don't know contaminated that's it
that's it that's it but now it's a peach
tree yeah a peach tree yeah peach
cobbler i love peach colors
yeah sure colors are great yeah but tree
see that's the thing is if it was a
cobbler peach tree
you know cobbler even if you like you
don't want the tree part in the cobbler
right right right but i wonder like if
her dessert is just like it's cut from
the bark and the wood that is the tree
itself
they're stealing your your your words
your incest you know
that's how it is i'm glad people like it
but i literally guess there's a great
that is we did i was like ancestors and
then i
had a i had a moment i had a moment in
the day right before i tweeted and i was
like how do i throw incest in here and
then i was like boom ancestors boom
that's way better that's way better of a
misspelling of mispronunciation yeah
word than incense
right right right marty taylor green and
her ancestors yeah that's way better
yeah way better
make ancestors great again i don't know
i'm just saying ar15 is trending
um still uh and will be for a while it
seems like um this is really the
it's let's see if i can get it if i can
get it back here ar15 is trending at
number
26. so it's at the bottom of the list
but it's still trending um it seems like
the reason why it's trending here is
they say the us department to review
police response and the uvalde shooting
i believe why ar 15 is trending here
is because the word is that the cops
were a little afraid to go into the
school to engage with this person
because
they assumed that he had an ar-15 or an
ar-15 style rifle right i believe is the
the case so you're telling me that the
people that are trained that got 40 of
the town city's budget
were afraid to go in
and stop a man with the gun
again that they were trained on how to
handle for a mass shooting well i mean
again
these people are well trained they're
well educated on what these weapons can
do because they use them so when you
know when you know when you're hit by an
ar-15 it doesn't just uh leave a hole in
your body it makes your flesh explode
right um they they know the danger like
it's not just about being shot it's
about being ripped apart and imagine if
it would you know blow someone's almost
their arm off if you're hitting the arm
imagine what it would do to a first
grader imagine imagine uh for a second a
high-powered ar-15 rifle being close
range inside a classroom with a with a
student that's trying to hide underneath
their desk that shouldn't have to hide
underneath their desk
is hit with a a a round from an ar-15
imagine what happens to them and i i
don't i don't want to steer away from
being graphic because i think it's very
important to be graphic because i think
that's what we're lacking right now is
to understand the magnitude of what is
happening
when these people are using these
weapons on our children
and it's not the back door the back door
is not the problem right the back door
did not blow these children apart that
is not what happened
so we need to get these facts straight
we need to get this out there i want to
show this uh video here speaking of
ar-15s um this is jim acosta
um talking to an nra board member here
we played this yesterday and then we're
gonna bring in ben hernandez um to talk
about uh how uh what he was talking to
ted cruz about in the restaurant uh
about these weapons but let's let's
listen to jim here um
ask judge phillip journey
an nra board member about ar-15s
with these mass shootings it keeps
coming back to the it keeps coming back
to the ar-15 and similar models why do
people need an ar-15 anyway
you know it's just a semi-automatic
rifle i mean you know if you want to be
prejudiced about the way it looks
but i was aware of what happened in the
94. semi-automatic firearms ban and
there were rifles of similar function
that just didn't look as ugly they
weren't black guns like a mini 14 ruger
mini 14. and of course the ruger mini 14
was appropriate and the ar-15 was not if
it had a bainet lug or a vertical rear
grip
i do want to ask you about the assault
weapons man but you know on the ar-15
how how is it that an 18-year-old can
buy an ar-15 style rifle and have 600
rounds of ammo with him like we saw in
uvalde
well it's he did not have any prior
convictions he didn't have any prior
issues that would have kept him from
purchasing one it's my understanding
from the news that he purchased it
through a firearms dealer he passed the
background check because he didn't have
any prior convictions
right but should an 18 year old have an
ar how he bought it should an a should
an 18 year old have an ar-15
what's he going to do i don't know 18
year old have one in the army
so they had military they had military
training in the army this 18 year old in
uvalde did not have military training he
turned 18 and he went out bought an
ar-15.
very confused there gabe he's very
confused yeah when you talk about this
stuff the comparison that i've seen
online this weekend of the uh
oh well
you know military versus not and it's
like i can't believe you're actually
going to bring that up again this is
someone in the military you are trained
you store your gun in a location you
have to register it they approach a
train you have to yeah there is a
complete protocol and run down that you
have to follow it isn't just like let me
go to walmart buy this gun walk out and
then go do what i want with it i know
right it's it's crazy but i want to
bring in uh ben hernandez
ben benjamin how are you
doing well yo oh great great great it's
great to have you um
benjamin you actually were
in a restaurant um with ted cruz and
asking him about some of these questions
that jim acosta was actually asking um
the judge in our nra board member here
what what was your what was your main
question did you did you have a set of
questions that you wanted to ask ted
cruz i mean
what what what message were you trying
to send
i mean i think the message that i was
trying to send is very simply can we do
the most basic things
around gun control and i think to me
you know his answers or lack of answers
tells me a lot right i have a lot of i
have a lot of thoughts on guns and what
we could do and everything that we need
to do i didn't start there i said okay
let's start with background checks can
we start with there that because it has
the support of the majority of the
american public can we do that and to
not hear
an answer
on that you know blaming the democrats
and this and that i'm like man i'm not
talking about the democrats i'm talking
about you you're my elected official
right so so that's what i was trying to
get across is like can we do something
basic on this if you don't want to do
something you know you don't want to do
everything that i think we should do is
can we start where there's common ground
on this
so tell us a little bit about your
background because this isn't the first
time that you've thought that you woke
up and thought about
um the issue of gun safety and the issue
of
maybe common sense
reform if you will this isn't the first
time you thought it so tell us about
your background tell us how you've come
to
to even
confront ted cruz to ask him these
questions your elected official ask him
for the answers to your questions
you know i feel this has been
certainly was a couple of days in the
making you know i was there at the
protest outside the georgia brown
convention center with indivisible
houston you know
my buddy daniel cohen we we went uh the
day on thursday we went and we put a cut
out of ted cruz in front of the nra's
doors you know it said we wrote on his
chest you know i murdered teachers and
children because his inaction
effectively is doing this right and we
put it in front of the doors and so you
know that i was in that mode for a
couple of days but also like
you know i since
2018
after santa fe
this blue wristband i've been wearing it
i got it at a march for our lives event
here in houston i've been wearing that
wristband every single day
since 2018 as a reminder to myself
right that we have not done anything
meaningful on gun violence in this
country and so for me it's just been
years of of building up and saying we
haven't done anything we need to do
something
and that's
kind of what you said in um 2m at the
restaurant i actually had the clip here
let's pull that up and now this video is
shot is it by someone who is who is with
you is that is it what i understand yeah
so my wife and i were having dinner at
sound sushi we were wrapping up the
dinner when uh i turn over and i look
and like ted cruz is walking i'm like
you gotta be kidding me right like you
you're not just gonna go and after
you've already speak at the end of the
convention like nothing and then go out
for for for for for dinner you know like
and come into the space where i am at
and not hear from me right right um and
so that's that was the thought so she
was the one who who captured the whole
interaction on video well it's about two
minutes and 20 seconds is the video here
on the internet and i believe it goes
from where you are
taking a selfie with ted cruz um to the
end to where they're actually escorting
you out of the restaurant um so let's
let's watch a bit of this and then i'll
let you comment and tell us more about
this interaction because
um the video that first went viral we
showed earlier it was kind of from a
bystander and they caught the very end
they didn't get this part so i want to
make sure we show this
okay you ready
okay hold on
all right one
two three
go
yeah
what about that
um yeah
he actually says the words to you you're
not listening to me and i don't think
your intent was
was to hear him out i think you know his
intentions you know what his opinions
are on these things i don't think it's a
secret that ted cruz takes money from
the nra and is going to stand with the
nra because they they fill his coffers
with money
he wasn't listening to you um and i
think that's probably
why texans should see this moment this
moment in the clip not the moment where
you know you got very passionate at the
very end and they they took you out to
get it to get you away from him because
he didn't want to speak to you anymore
but i think
the main issue here is that ted cruz
is not listening he's not hearing and i
don't believe it's just ted cruz i think
it's greg abbott i think it's dan
patrick i don't think it's just the
politicians that you have elected in the
state of texas i think there's
politicians all over this country who
are not listening they're only telling
us what we're supposed to do not
actually listening to what we want to
have done like that's the whole point of
a democratic constitutional republic
give us your thoughts on that yeah
absolutely i mean i that's the tragedy
here right you know in the face of
something like uvaldi where you should
be listening to people and listening to
what we could do to prevent uh you know
another
mass shooting where elementary children
lied you know you're not even willing to
listen you're trying to give me the same
canned response that you gave earlier in
the week you know that was like what was
so offensive to me is like talking about
the democrat like i don't care about the
democrats man you're ted cruz like i
want to know what you will do and if you
can get behind something like this
you're not let you know at some point
later i think he calls me ignorant like
like you just met me i've been watching
you for a minute i've been listening to
you as my representative for a very long
minute and you're going to call me
ignorant based on this interaction i
wasn't offended that he called me
anywhere but it tells you a lot about
how he thinks of people and his
constituents right instead of saying
like okay let me listen to you what what
what should we do benjamin right and i'm
here to listen right right but you you
want to throw these canned responses and
deflect responsibility i wasn't having
it you know and i'm not going to let you
go and give me your spiel and do the
same thing you've done over and over
because you came into the space where i
was having dinner right and you thought
that was a safe space i don't know why
but here's what's interesting he directs
me to his nra speech you know to go
ahead and watch that you know in his
speech he complains about the elites who
live in gated communities and have
private security you know you know who
kicked me out of that restaurant his
private security
there could be no place closer to the
gated upscale communities of houston
than we were dining that night and so
i'm like really
that's that's your response when you're
the one who's actually doing these
things gaslighting the rest of us well
yeah i think i think you completely hit
it on the head right there like the gas
lighting i mean we've seen it again and
again right it is like you know when he
gave the interview with sky news he said
i'm sorry you feel that way right i'm
sorry you don't like american
exceptionalism or whatever you said
right like it's that dismissive quality
of politicians especially republicans
who say i'm here to listen i'm here to
care you know i'm here for you and then
immediately
we'll say
you know
you you think what you think and you
feel how you feel but i'm really not
going to change the opinion i have or at
least i'm not going to change opinion
based on the nra payroll that i'm on but
i think the other thing too is like yeah
you know he says go and watch this
speech that i gave today at the nra you
go back and watch his speech or
or trump's speech and you see in there
that they keep hitting the same thing
which is
one single point of entry we need high
security we need guards we need teachers
armed we need uh to really go after the
mentally ill and lock them up in mental
institutions and then the other one is
also how you know we need to um
we need to not ban guns and it's the
democratic policies that would actually
cause more or if anything the policies
that they're introducing or or have
suggested would actually do nothing
you know they're the we're the party the
democrats of the party that uh have not
contributed anything to the conversation
when in fact if you look at there are
literal receipts things are introduced
into the floor and said hey let's vote
on this and they say
no we're not going to but you know
that's that's a good point gabe because
there was a time in our history and i
think people it and it was recent
history where the democratic party had
an arm in their party that they really
did take a lot of money from the nra
they did
they did stop any kind of common sense
uh gun laws
the the shift
in the political spectrum though
is that most people have common sense
thoughts around firearms like it's not
uncommon for someone who is even an nra
member themselves to have common sense
thoughts
around gun safety and what we should and
should not do in this country when it
comes to
guns especially
these assault style guns
the the shift is and i think this is
where they're losing their narrative
when they're talking about banning back
doors the shift in the politics is that
there's only one party that actually has
the backbone to stand against a handful
of families in this country who
manufacture these weapons because that's
really what we're up against here we are
up against a handful of families very
wealthy families who have inherited
these manufacturers in this country
that absolutely do not care what happens
to other people in this country as long
as they get to get their profits from
the technology that they have been able
to develop throughout the decades and
they want to put it on our streets for
pure blooded profit excuse the pun but
that is truly what is happening is we we
have got ourselves in a situation where
only one political party is willing to
protect those handful of families
to
put their technology that their
companies that they inherited that they
own
on the streets no matter what the
consequence and that is really where
we're at in the political game here and
that is why i believe that people like
ted cruz won't listen because if they do
start listening they're going to realize
that the money that they take is blood
money it is the blood is on their hands
and they're they're definitely not
um strong enough they're cowards
to admit that and he doesn't admit it in
this video i wanna i wanna finish it up
here because he really does get cowardly
here when you really start to uh talk
about things well i think as soon as he
looks over and realizes your wife is
recording still that's what like there's
that look of like
uh okay we gotta we gotta deal with this
situation right now
so let let's finish here um and then
i'll let you tell us about what happened
after the video because that's what i'm
really interested in because we don't
see the the after what what what ensued
after if there was anything
[Music]
it is harder it is harder
when there are more guns
everywhere
[Music]
oh
and why did you come here to the
convention
why when 19 children died 19 children
died
it's on your hands that is on your hands
right through that one turn
so benjamin
i want to tell you that i think you
speak for a lot of americans um in this
video
um when especially at the end when
you're saying that it's on his hands
because he said things and um to you
that like oh the democrats are
filibustering um it's the democrats
democrats democrats when he is still
would be the solution right
his party has a lot of control so much
control over the state of texas and the
gun laws in the state of texas
that greg abbott cheered
cheered when they passed a law and and
was was was actually upset that that
california had more gun sales than texas
um
and i think you speak for most people
out there most parents especially when
they see the tragedy that it's not just
happened in uvalde um sandy hook uh
el paso
marjory stoneman douglas in parkland
florida i mean the list goes on and on
and on here that that at some point at
some point something has to be done but
what i what i want to know here is
we kind of get the end of the video um
and i don't know if it's because twitter
will only let a two minute and twenty
second video be posted uh or if this
video continued what what actually
happened once you left the restaurant um
can you tell us a little bit about that
was did ted cruz reach out to you at all
as he said look i want to have a
conversation i want to have a reasonable
discussion with you i mean has he
reached out at all his team reached out
at all to you no no i mean his his uh
private security was the one who kicked
me out of the restaurant a lot of people
think it was a restaurant it wasn't it
was just two people from his security
and and uh
you know somebody sitting at his table
um but no one like you know when we get
there to the door i'm like no i'm
leaving man because that one of the
securities like you want to get arrested
i'm like i'm leaving man i'm leaving
right you know
what like what i mean like what on what
because you talk to him
i mean that's that's what they do right
my goal is like
you know what was more important to me
was to make sure that
i let ted cruz know that he's
responsible for his inaction right and
so once i said that and and they got me
to the door i was gonna leave anyways
right right no interest in sharing a
space with ted cruz beyond every you
know second that i have to
um and so yeah we left and then i looked
down at my shoe and i was like what why
am i wearing flip-flops turns out i
ripped my shoe in the process the sole
of my shoe because i was pushing so hard
to stand my ground and hold my place
while they're yanking me
that i ended up ripping my shoes so that
that could tell you like i don't know
that the video captures that but a lot
of force was going into that and then
you saw the moment when i turned on like
who's holding me man like i'm trying
yeah we're trying to talk to him you
guys are you guys are the aggressors
here ted cruz is the one who is play you
know and that in the same thing happened
in the sky news interview where like you
go like you guys are you know arm and
arm taking the photo or like the photo
but just like in the sky news like he's
the one who is going to take more
advance on putting his hands on you to
be like look
that's that's nice and all but i'm not
going to really care for it and like
they're the aggressors they're the ones
who are now con you know
you know checking you they're the ones
that are pulling you back
right so i don't know if there's some
sort of case for you here but like that
is something too it's like they're the
ones that technically kind of
made the physical touch they made the
assault on you so
yeah i don't know
well i i appreciate you um standing your
ground and really making your voice be
heard let me ask you if ted cruz's
office did reach out if they did reach
out and want to have a conversation with
him i don't think you you wouldn't be
afraid to have a conversation with ted
cruz in private or in public would you
yeah private or in public better for me
in public because more people need to
hear the answers right
questions that that people people
want answers to so i'd love that
opportunity um because
it was unresolved you didn't give me an
answer right i asked about a simple
thing i have a lot of thoughts about you
know what we should do about gun
regulations in this country but i wasn't
going to all of my thoughts i was going
to the simple thing where i know a
majority of americans are behind and so
yeah let's have that conversation and
let's make it public why not well what
are you afraid of right um so i'd love
that opportunity yeah because you'd say
what are you afraid of but of course for
him he's like i'm afraid of everything
right well i mean obviously in the in
the confrontation that was caught on uh
several different cameras in
in the restaurant there um that he was
very uncomfortable with not not only
just hearing the things that you had to
say but having to
to formulate answers that was other than
his
you know his go-to's democrats fault um
you know
more guns
is the answer you know this
because they continue on this
this this idea and they they're really
losing ground on some of their arguments
like they're back to the reason why we
have to have ar-15s as wild hogs like
literally that is where they're back to
in some of these arguments matt gatz was
tweeting it the other day that the
reason why our constitutional right
affords us to have ar-15s is because we
have we have feral hogs in certain parts
of the country like we've had barrel
hogs in this country for hundreds of
years and we didn't have ar-15 style
right i also wasn't aware that we had
that many hog hunters out there right
like well
and here's the thing i i actually am not
against someone who wants to
hunt wild game to have the kind of
weapons that they need to have i just
believe that someone should actually be
responsible and held accountable for
those weapons to hunt with those weapons
for wild game i mean if you really need
a rifle that has a high capacity
magazine um to shoot wild game i come
from a rural area i went deer hunting as
a kid i we didn't we we took deer rifles
that held six shots and really honestly
that was that was triple doing it i mean
if you had to shoot twice
um at a whitetail deer because
white-tailed deer are not heavily armed
they don't wear body armor i mean this
is wild game and if you need more than
two maybe three shots
you probably need to pick a different
recreation or just
just go to the shoot yes head back to
the shooting range and just saying maybe
there for a little bit but but that
their arguments are falling apart here
with the back door talk um how do you
feel when they when they do this thing
where they try to distract from every
because you said you went to several
march of uh of our lives and i think um
david hogg actually announced was it
yesterday i believe that they're going
to go to dc on june 11th uh which um
i've already suggested they gave that we
live stream that um that rally or parts
of that rally but depending on the time
of day and the stuff how long it is but
we want to try to live stream that to
get that out to everybody but how do you
feel about some of this dodginess of the
of the actual issue when they talk about
back doors and
hardening our schools as if our children
should go to prisons to be educated
i mean i think that that's why i say
like you know like ted cruz just has to
be the unluckiest guy because like you
know
i wasn't having any of that right like i
think that's why people i've heard
people like wow you interrupted him you
don't talk yeah damn right because when
he was trying to give me those canned
answers i wasn't having i was like stop
like i'm not interested in that let's go
to background checks that's what i'm
asking you about give me an answer on
that give me an answer on that give me
and so i wasn't trying to let him escape
because you know i've seen what they do
and i don't i don't have any patience
for that right like i don't like i don't
have patience that i don't want your
canned answer i'm asking you a very
simple question why can't you get behind
something that the majority of americans
can get behind right and you don't have
an answer i don't have patience for your
garbage answers and there are garbage
answers because in the face of tragedy
that's all you can come up with right i
don't have time well and he's he's
here's the thing he's probably not also
the one that's coming up with the
answers right he's going to the nra or
the nra is coming to him and the
spokesperson says listen you're going to
have to run through these three bullet
points don't ever mention these things
but definitely keep reiterating these
things we want to distract away because
it's not the guns it's the back door or
it's the teacher or it's you know the
fact that we you know we don't have high
walls or or you know barbed wire fencing
right that's the problem it's not the
fact that we have more guns than people
in this country and then getting one is
probably more you know it's easier than
buying a pack of cigarettes or buying a
lotto ticket yeah
benjamin i appreciate you being in this
fight as many parents in this country do
um and i hope you continue to stay and
you continue to stay vocal and i
actually hope i i actually am hoping
that you get a chance to talk to ted
cruz um one on one in a situation where
you can get some of the answers to your
questions he is your representative i
feel like he owes you um the time just
five ten minutes to sit down with you
and answer some of the questions that he
was
clearly unable to answer in the
restaurant there benjamin tell us where
where our viewers can find you where
they can follow you because i know
you're you're gonna stay in this fight
um and it's vitally important that
everyone stick together um to make sure
that that this country's safe
yeah definitely follow me on twitter at
you see the handle there the benjamin
hdz um you know another thing that i
want to talk about is
the last couple of days here a lot of
people have asked me you know like i
said they say you're here i'm like man
i'm just doing what i needed to do
but a question has come you know the
natural question is like how can
we do this with our elected officials
and i think like with the indivisible
houston group you know uh i think one
thing that we're gonna do two nights
from now on thursday we're in a live
stream um sort of uh a a a conversation
when one we're gonna take people through
the you know how we got to it about
answer the question everybody one wants
to know it was this stage right i'm like
no like y'all like answer that question
so take people through the video the
behind the scenes but then also
leave them with
if you want to how can you do this with
your elected officials and create that
playbook to challenge them because the
reality is when they're hiding like ted
cruz behind private security and in his
gated community even though that's what
he accuses other people of you know when
they're hiding when you find them in the
street challenge them and this is how
you should challenge them because
there's a way to do that right um you
know and so we're going to take people
through a playbook um you know and give
people and empower people really to do
this with their elected officials and
this is not a partisan thing hell
whether it's a republican democrat
independent libertarian whatever it is
if your elected official isn't creating
the space
for constituents to ask questions and
they answer you go out and you make that
space if you see them on the street in
the grocery store at the theater or in a
restaurant you create that space because
they're actively hiding from us when
they represent us
well thank you thank you
yeah tell us tell us where that's going
to be
yeah we're going to stream it we uh have
a the details in a couple of hours but
we're going to stream it on facebook
live um and also on youtube but you'll
you'll see details right there from my
handle coming out in a couple of hours
okay and then also some invisible
houston handle um you know because we we
a lot of people are asking like yeah we
need to do this how do we especially
after watching beto o'rourke do it as
well right confronting greg but i think
there's there's there's a movement
that's starting that people say wait a
minute i don't have to be
passive in this conference this is a
conversation and i need to make space
for myself and we need to make them have
this conversation i agree with you so so
when you when you tweet that out
everyone go follow ben uh at the
benjamin hdz on twitter the handles
there on the screen and we'll put it in
the the chat as well here um so so go
follow uh benjamin on twitter and
benjamin if you can send that to me or
gabe and we'll try to retweet it out to
see if we can get that out to as many
people as as we possibly can and get the
audience to help us uh circulate that
around so that way anyone who wants to
watch um that live stream can do that
thank you for joining us i really and
and come back please come back and give
us an update now we want to talk to you
more about this issue it's not going
away and right now right
even even if there is some common sense
uh reform passed we still cannot take
our eye off the ball because uh these
these folks that are
that are out for the blood money of the
nra are not gonna stop um it's obvious
that they're willing to do almost
anything give you any kind of excuse
they can't even blame a back door
for the events that happen
in uvalde uh the tragedy of the 19 dead
children and two dead teachers it's
it's a shame that we have to do that so
thank you benjamin for joining us
everyone go check out um benjamin on
twitter to make sure you catch that live
stream uh i i'm i'm interested and i
think we might uh take a look at that so
we'll have you back soon benjamin i
appreciate it everyone stick around
we'll be right back thanks so much for
this break have a good one benjamin
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reach dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lid loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around
we are at the bottom of the hour 35
minutes into the second hour
we do two hours
every single weekday monday through whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what is this
what are you doing
every single week day monday through
friday for two straight hours
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
streaming live on youtube twitter and
twitch so don't forget to go subscribe
to the youtube channel
and vitally important that you do not
miss a thing an episode and if you do
that's the beauty gabe is it's all over
there right it is yeah the other place
there the other place is that we sign my
cast on mine is touch facebook what we
have a ton of new listeners on facebook
we are excited about having those
listeners on facebook and to the
facebook listeners out there if you want
to subscribe to the youtube channel that
link is right there on the post um every
single broadcast so if you want to come
subscribe to catch some of our other
clips that we also do that we also put
up and we've been appearing in on the
midas touch youtube channel i don't want
to
leave that like go subscribe to the
minus touch um youtube channel if you're
not already and there's a lot of cool
clips over there that they're putting
out on trending takes and we've taken
clips from the show here and put them
over there they've done really well so
don't forget to do that also if you
only want the audio version you can
download it on apple spotify google any
of the directories out there
and we've got a ton of new people
listening on the on the podcast
directories holy moly our audience is
growing here
it's growing like crazy so thank you to
all the viewers
out there they seem to really like that
interview with benjamin we definitely
should have him back message him and i
said uh you know anytime you want to
come on the show during the week just
let me know and we'll try to uh we'll
try to hopefully he sends us that link
we'll pay attention to get that out to
you guys on twitter we'll try to tweet
it around see if we can get some folks
to retweet that thing
that way
that way we can
get the message out about the live
stream that benjamin was talking about
that seems very interesting yeah uh very
interesting live stream there they're
talking i think he said it was
individual houston it's going to talk
about how to approach politicians and
have conversations with him because
that's ultimately what he was trying to
do with ted cruz and it went south when
ted cruz kind of put his hands on him
and told him get the hell away from me i
don't want to hear anything you got to
say because the truth does not suit me
just the same way as he did in the sky
news interview when the journalist not
not just a citizen that voted
in the election where represents a
journalist
who is asking him questions yeah which
some may some may say that the
journalist has more responsibility to
ask the politician questions than maybe
even the voter does right right the
voter's responsibility is making sure
that they disseminate the information
that the press gives them
about the politician and make the
correct choice but he won't he wouldn't
even answer the press's question he yeah
yeah yeah well i mean that's you know
that is that is uh par for the course
right they do not want to actually have
a discussion they just want to
throw their
their uh
you know pre um
established answers down your throat to
say like listen this is what i want and
you saw in the video right you saw it
here in this video with benjamin you saw
it in the sky news interview you know
any time they're like ah look look look
look
there's another video too and i think we
missed it the other day um let me see if
i can find it here it it actually it
shows the same ted cruz doing the same
thing where he's ignoring and not
listening to uh someone
oh what was the video go go ahead and
i'll i'll see if i can
so yeah so basically what i was saying
was like you know you've got people like
ted cruz you know and other republicans
who fear
fear for their lives let's say
uh who don't want to be interviewed they
don't want to be questioned right they
they don't want you to have the ability
to speak up and ask
a simple question is like what are you
doing about background checks right
that's as simple as the question is and
ted cruz says oh you know what i
actually talked about uh a lot of this
in my 30 minute speech at the nra
convention today you should go check it
out right now
when i count down to them exactly not
even humoring the idea to ask just to to
come back to benjamin and say well
here's my here are my beliefs and this
is what my bill did instead he said go
watch my speech that i just did at the
nra convention doesn't even want to
listen to the question doesn't even want
to hear
anything i mean like
i can only imagine
what a parent
if they were to get in the proximity of
ted cruz
and in a
you know in a somewhat uh
kind of
reserved controlled manner could ask the
questions of what are you doing to stop
this
and i could very much imagine that ted
cruz would gaslight dismiss
and you know denigrate this other person
who just experienced this loss based on
the things that he was not doing
to protect
their children right i 100 guarantee
that he would do the same tactic he
would follow the same list of things he
talks about and doesn't want to talk
about and then bring out security to
manhandle um
a mother or a father that had lost their
their child
right well here is here's another um
john
um
lyra i believe is his name he's running
for congress against tony gonzalez who
is the representative um there in uvalde
he confronted ted cruz now this is may
25th
um that he confronted him here's another
instance of ted cruz
absolutely not getting that he has to
listen to people
and that's the whole point one of the
whole point of politics is to listen
you're there to represent the voice of
the people and when you're not listening
you're not representing their voice so
let's listen
[Music]
well i hope you make a lot of money
i'm gonna be knocking on your door once
i'm up there sir i'm basically telling
ted cruz hey i'm going to be your
colleague yeah and that and that is see
you on the hill now now rather rather
john here can win um
you know because it is
it is a situation where we have a lot of
hurdles in front of us um with
gerrymandered districts the way they try
to suppress the vote we can't let that
stand in our way of making sure that our
voices are heard and this is the whole
susan collins sidewalk chalk and the
scotus getting extra security because
people are talking loudly right right
the one thing that benjamin did that ted
cruz did not like
is he spoke loudly right in a restaurant
and he said loud things that ted cruz
did not want people to hear yeah dan is
that's ultimately the the crime
that benjamin committed was that he said
loudly the things that ted cruz did not
want him to hear right
right and and the reason why is because
they have they have a cult-like
atmosphere right now in the republican
party and that cult-like atmosphere is
absolutely centered around guns and
centered around taking away your rights
and using any means necessary even the
threat
of guns we've got a uh
uh might get mine
super chat she says they don't want to
harden our schools
they want to harden our hearts not going
to happen that is a damn good point
that's a damn good point they want us to
ignore this fact they want us to get
used to the fact that our children are
in danger
just get used to it just get used to it
america just get used to it because it's
here to stay your children you have to
worry
every single minute of every single day
rather your children are safe in schools
i want to even show you
i mean there are you know it's it's it
is tuesday may 31st and you know i
guarantee
we are are they they i want to say the
gop they're already trying to move on
right they're already oh well yeah well
i believe that's what the police were
trying to do in uvalde is trying to
stall long enough till the next mass
shooting school shooting right so that
way they don't have to keep coming out
in front of a microphone it would be the
next town that would have to come out in
front of a microphone for the national
media um speaking of being cult-like
around guns
this
this video right here i know this may
seem insignificant to people like oh
this is just kind of funny
this is really seriously where their
culture is at folks
their guns are not are not just are not
just for protection anymore
they are using them as a political
weapon that is what they're using them
and i don't just mean like oh
they're trying to do policy
they're trying to intimidate with these
weapons watch this video this is a
continuation of our series of 1911's
paying tribute to president trump the
rally cry 1911. this one is about the
manga rallies the presidential rallies
that president trump is so famous for
the finish on this is a cerakote it's a
new style that we do with the gold
flakes really really beautiful
i don't know if they're talking about
like the uh the coup attempt as a manga
rallies and why they haven't yeah yeah
i'm not sure what this did this
it really is a [ __ ] cult you know i
wanna i wanna i wanna challenge people
if anyone ever brings up these guns
again right
if there's a shooting i'm just gonna
automatically default to
that person was killed with a trump gun
right
and just push that push that messaging
it was a trump gun that killed those
people it was a trump gun it was a trump
gun it was a trump gun
because he's saying i don't [ __ ] care
anymore i'm going to assign those deaths
to trump and anyone else in
in congress or in the senate or local
representatives or governor like i think
we should i think we should rename the
guns
to whoever the person was where the mass
shooting happened
and that representative senator governor
whoever
voted to remove restrictions right the
greg abbott gun yeah well i haven't i
called i called
i called the the buffalo shooter the
manga king mass shooter
right because
of his
his little memorandum that he wrote
beforehand it was obvious that he was a
trumped-up white dude um who was allowed
to buy guns the minute he turned 18
right um which we should
listen
gabe how long was have you rented cars
before have you rented a car
how old do you have to be to rent a car
you know 25.
that seems i wonder i wonder why the the
rental car industry is so concerned
that you have to be a responsible driver
uh to drive this 300 000 or 3000 pound
vehicle down the road yeah i wonder i
wonder why
that may be it could that seems kind of
funny right i don't know it's almost
like it's like a moving vehicle that is
a is a huge two-ton uh
like weapon i don't know well the other
thing too is or you're not killing
people right right right well the other
thing too right is like you're in a
development [ __ ] right
well the rationale is 25 you know your
your your brain has fully developed
right you are an adult right that is the
way in which
uh
they they reason with certain ages but
like
you know 18 to buy lotto ticket 18 to
buy nude uh nude mag 21 to buy
cigarettes 18 to serve in the military
25
to uh to rent a car sometimes if you
want to rent a more expensive car then
it requires certain insurance you have
to be 30 years old oh really well you
know i
this sounds like because i don't want to
stifle anyone's sexual chaos or sexual
anarchy because you mentioned porno mags
um but you know
again again we continue this this
nonsense that we can't
regulate something like literally the
the fact that you have to have a license
to drive a car the fact that you you
have to get a permit
to practice yep before you get a license
to drive a car
and then you have to get insurance you
have to buy insurance at the rental car
company you have to be 25 to rent a car
i mean all these things and we can't
just simply say hey maybe maybe we
should just consider some of these
common sense kind of things
around a weapon i i'm i'm not saying
that we should or we shouldn't ban right
all assault rifles i think it's a good
idea to look at that that should be on
the table but i want to tell all the
people out there
that do
believe in common sense regulation and
you own guns you own ar-15s you like the
ar-15
you better start coming to the table
fast like it is it is a situation in
this country that i don't think there's
a lot of time left um before
some of these laws could actually get
out of hand in the opposite direction if
you believe in the second amendment so
if you believe in the second amendment
if you believe what it says to be true
you should get to the table as fast as
you can and you should be on the right
side of this because i think that's the
other thing that happens in this gun
stuff
is they have convinced people
that the
the actual arguments that you make like
oh well you know alcohol and you know
all this stuff they convince people
that are on the right side of common
sense gun reform that they're on the gun
side right like there's the gun side and
there's the ban gun side right there's
only two sides in this country and
you're either with the gun people are
you with the anti-gun people and that's
just not the truth that's not the
[ __ ] truth you people out there who
own guns who want to keep owning guns
that believe in common sense gun reform
i i
i implore you to go and have
conversations with people who actually
want to ban ar-15s have a real
conversation with them because i think
there's more common ground with those
folks
than than the people who absolutely want
unfettered access that want to make sure
to dump massive amounts of profits
into a handful of families that own
these gun manufacturers so that way they
can dump massive amounts of campaign
contributions in the politicians pockets
right um i believe that
that is where we need to be so if you
are out there and you do believe in the
second amendment and you think it's your
right and you we shouldn't ban ar-15s
but you believe in common sense gun
reform common sense stuff like how you
store it how you buy it how many you can
buy what you can own where you can own
it where you can shoot it i mean all
that stuff i believe there's a lot of
people out there that believe in common
sense gun reform right that still want
to own ar-15s
you got to get to the table fast you got
to get to the table and start talking to
people who want to ban them you are not
on the side
of the gun lobby you are not on the side
of the nra you are on the side of people
who want to ban the ar-15s negotiate
with them talk to them have round tables
this is good conversation to have i
believe the american people can fix this
problem i truly believe they can
regardless of what the end result is the
fixing of the problem is to make sure we
just don't slaughter innocent people
rather in a grocery store or school or
theater it's crazy that that is just the
bare minimum if we could not like just
just the fact that you have to ask that
you have to bring that out there and be
like can we just not
right slaughter can we not just kill
these children and rip them apart
like that that should be like just
i mean as a christian guys
republicans
how would you protect human life
by throwing more guns on the street i
don't know if jesus would want that guys
i'm pretty sure jesus would probably say
not so much on the warfare more love and
peace yeah jesus cometh with an ar-15 i
don't know i think that's i mean that
sounds like a republican jesus who's
like white
super yo
and has an ar-15 rolled around with two
[ __ ] mega guns in his hands right it
happens yeah
speaking of trumped up christians uh
jeannie thomas of course is
our uh our our title today genie ku
thomas because i believe this is another
thing we can't keep our eyes off of is
this this [ __ ] nonsense about the law
clerks they want to they want to hand
over here's a one person tweeting
supreme court demands law clerks hanover
phone records and roe v wade leaker
investigation wait january 6th
commission you have jeannie thomas tex
calls and nothing being done
again
i believe there is stuff being done
about the the uh
the text messages and the january 6.
speaking of that game we are going to
live stream all those public yep public
hearings hey look here someone has some
text messages oh jeannie thomas
someone tweets let's not forget jamie
thomas is an insurrectionist and there
are and there are texts to prove it i
wonder who this is let's see if we can
hear what these texts say
hello and welcome to a dramatic reading
of text messages sent to mark meadows
from jenny thomas help this great
president stand firm mark you are the
leader
with him who is standing for america's
constitutional governance at the
precipice
the majority knows biden in the left is
attempting the greatest heist
of our history sounds like sydney and
her team are getting inundated with
evidence of fraud
make a plan release the quantum and save
us from the left taking america down i
can't see them okay okay obviously this
is gabe's ninjas in a [ __ ] wig now
gabe the only thing that's missing is
when these text first came out it was
during christmas time and you actually
made like a little christmas video now
of course you're kind of keeping the
same right ambiance here now this video
has been released for i don't know a
couple this is march 25th i think we're
we are two months after the fact right
and i think really the text
yeah maybe a couple days before that so
yeah we're looking at a little over two
months that
this leak
happened
and i made this video right but here's
the thing is these these text messages
are so [ __ ] funny and the reason why
they're funny is you're like who would
text this [ __ ]
right yeah who the greatest heist of our
time what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you're right the crap really she
released believed
the kraken like she's reading her
facebook feed
and typing it out to mark meadows make a
plan mark yeah who is standing next to
the president united states who's trying
to overthrow our constitution the actual
greatest heist yeah
of our country's history i mean trump
said he's writing a book
writing a book it'll probably be a
picture book honestly and it'll probably
have someone you know coloring alliance
forum but it's called the greatest heist
of our century in our century
i forget what it's called but anyway
it's a memoir that's what i said
let's finish the text message here
because i think it's important to
not just read but hear gabe read these
text messages
i can't see americans swallowing the
obvious fraud
just going with one more thing with no
freaking consequences
the whole coup and now this
we just cave to people wanting biden to
be anointed
many of us can continue the gop charade
and this has been a dramatic reading of
text messages sent to mark meadows from
jenny thomas so
wait wait wait wait for it wait for it
i'm going to pause this because here is
the dismount on this video series that
everyone needs to pay attention to like
this is the reason why forget about the
[ __ ] text messages forget about the
fire in the background the voice this
dismount here with the pipe watch the
pipe dismount folks and if you're
listening out there on the directories
you definitely need to come onto the
youtube channel to see this dismount
maybe we'll post this video on the
youtube on our satire yeah yeah that way
that we can all find it what watch the
dismount here with the pipe
[Laughter]
this text message right here this is yes
there is there are a couple things in
here the no freaking consequences right
keep in mind to everyone who's seeing
this and listening
these texts i this verbatim i didn't
change a thing out of these texts i just
pasted them and then had them come in
when i said the words now the two things
i want to call it is
no freaking consequences one she
couldn't even lie or she couldn't even
swear right uh but she goes freaking not
freaking freaking not [ __ ] frickin
and then also biden to be anointed what
you mean like elected you mean like
sworn in what the [ __ ] yeah well she
wants trump to be anointed as the key
right
and again it's all projection it's all
projections she said i can't see
americans swallowing the obvious fraud
like americans didn't swallow the fraud
of trump being president like we
understood how the the electoral college
worked we were upset
right and we and we understood that how
big of a fraud he was and how big of a
fraud it was that he was going to be
some great [ __ ] president right and
and then she says just going with one
more thing with no freaking consequence
he continually every single day avoided
consequences at every turn because he
would blame it on someone else like it
was always someone else's fault he was
[ __ ] imbeached twice for crying out
loud he would be impeached for the exact
thing that she's tweeting about and she
said the whole coup
and now this like literally what
what you're you're advocating for a coup
and
people want biden to be anointed you
mean like voters who voted for him to be
sworn in as for what the [ __ ] is she
talking about and then these people are
[ __ ] wild man
that the gop charade which i'm with her
there yeah many of us
cannot continue this we cannot genie
thomas you are correct when you say many
of us cannot continue
the gop charade genie thomas you actual
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] no not freaking
[ __ ] piece of trash [ __ ] why in the
[ __ ] charade
i just love the the sound when you're
when you're there will be more i'm sure
well there's always more text messages
with these people they're the ones that
y'all honor buttons laptop emails
emails
oh my god they just won't quit they
won't quit and they're not gonna quit
and they're gonna talk about the [ __ ]
leak they're gonna try to distract you
with the leak but the real story is is
that jeannie thomas the wife of a
supreme court justice tried and
attempted a sitting a sitting supreme
made decisions based on evidence of the
actual coup and the plot of the coup
this is this is insanity that we somehow
are supposed to be super [ __ ] pissed
about a decision leaking that they're
gonna make right
we're supposed to be [ __ ] mad that a
decision that they're supposed to make
that they wrote
there's no they're not like oh this is
we this is totally false this is not
this is [ __ ] they wrote
they wrote this [ __ ] yeah again i didn't
make this [ __ ] up i literally copied
and then pasted
the text
when i was editing nothing has been
changed nothing has been edited all of
their grammar mistakes and their choice
of words it is 100 them despite the fact
that it annoys the [ __ ] out of me
i guess the question here now
is now that we're investigating the
leaker the laker hmm
i wonder if they were diapers too
once we find out that it's a that it's a
conservative uh law clerk
once we find the leaker my question is
are we going to investigate clarence and
jeannie thomas to see what their actual
participation was
in the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup and i'm going to leave it
there we are at the top of the second
hour thanks for joining us just like you
join us every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific streaming live on youtube
twitter and twitch and simulcasting to
the midas touch facebook page check us
out on all the directories apple spotify
and google and until tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
meal born head ass speaking